tell you what pretty solid performance
by the nascent xB in this movie I'll say
that 33 so the 33 is a true story about
these miners they're working in a mine
this mine collapses in on them they're
all trapped down there they're irritable
they're starving and now it's a rescue
movie one of the things I remember when
this happened I remember seeing it on
the news it was a big deal and a happy I
was really interested to see the movie
based on that event right so being
brutally honest right up front pretty
early on in this movie I got that
made-for-tv vibe it's not like this
movie was made for TV and there's
somewhere along the lines in production
they were like yeah we're gonna
theatrically release this and that
feeling never really subsided you just
felt like that the entire time that
people didn't do a good job in this
made-for-tv movie that became
theatrically released Antonio Banderas
did a good job in this movie Gabriel
burns in this movie that dude that plays
ork season 300 he didn't good job in
this movie but they're not like
career-defining roles or anything like
that you're not gonna look at them
really oh my gosh it's all gonna be
different from here on for that actor in
the movie it's serviceable and there you
go you move on but I liked this movie
did have moments of heart in it that's
what the movies going for it you feel
the bond between these people who are
all trapped you feel the frustration but
you know they kind of take it out on
each other but they're not really pissed
at each other it's just a situational
circumstance they get to eat a little
bit of tuna fish every day and that's
yeah you're gonna get irritated so props
to the moment of heart what I hated were
those awkward ass moments of attempted
humor I guess like there's this one
scene where the like oh this may be our
last meal so they're all visioning these
great meals that they're having when
they're really like kind of sucking down
tuna fish that could have been fine it
could have been executed so well but at
a point this one guy is like standing
next to a cow is like hey fresh milk
anyone want some it came across as such
an awkward attempt at humor that just
killed the mood for the entire scene
you're like all right well the scenes
wasted now and there's this other side
scenario slash story in this movie where
this one guy is married but he had a
mistress on the side and the mistress
and the wife bicker and kind of jab at
each other like ah she got me this time
I can't believe she threw me out it's
like yeah the guys down there dying in a
mind let's stay in the pocket here let's
not miss the point this game of cross is
a really awkward attempt at humor from
someone who didn't know how to execute
humor in a movie and biopics like this
you know not everything that happens in
them at
happened in real life so in real life
I'm sure this guy had a mistress did you
have to have it in the movie if you're
gonna have it don't execute it all stick
and awkward humor guys in the end the 33
was a serviceable movie if you need to
move you right now to kind of give you
the feels in a couple scenes everyone in
the movie did a fine job it is a neat
rescue movie about hope and humanity
people trying to save people as a kid I
remember watching a made-for-tv movie
about a little girl who got stuck down a
well and people had to drill down
together that is this movie but
larger-scale literally it is so I can't
really justify paying full ticket price
for a made-for-tv feeling movie but I
will say the 33 would probably be a
better time if you drunk yeah no it's a
party okay so what is your favorite
rescue movie of all time whatever it is
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]